what's up believe nation it's Evan I'm
pumped to be back here I'm testing a new
format for this MA
I made a commitment to trying to be on
with you guys once a week Thursday to
answer questions sometimes through
having guests on board and we do it
together and sometimes just by myself
entrepreneur AMA doing the live Q&A with
you so I'm testing a new format today
hopefully this works as you can see I've
got some stuff on the side here where is
it over here over here we've got the
live chat happening here on the side
this little black box that will show as
we get more subscribers that subscribe
to the channel so it's about
experimentation and we'll see how it
goes so welcome guys to the chat Rebecca
ice crystal Herman hey we got a
subscriber Denise Smith I love it thank
you guys for joining in if you have
questions start putting them in the live
chat if you tagged me it's gonna be a
lot easier for me to see you see how
fast the chats already going so you may
have to write it a couple times to get
my attention so let's go through here we
go we got I don't know how much time
we'll see how much energy we got next
okay who's up first
checkmate dev who's your biggest role
model my biggest role model are behind
me my parents there's a picture which
way do I turn this way right so that's
me when I'm like eight those are my
parents who taught me believe you know
they didn't really care much about
business but they taught me how to be a
human being and had to care for others
and believed myself and belief comes
from them and so that still runs through
everything that I do and I'm super
grateful and that's why they're up on my
wall in the middle there's five pictures
you can only see I guess four from this
angle and they're right in the middle of
my wall that I look at every day when I
come into my office thank you for the
question way to kick us off what do we
got next
Hey right here how you doing Evan I'm
doing great great I love it I love a
chance to talk to the leaf nation answer
some questions thank you for joining in
next Evan Carmichael morning how do you
want to be remembered I don't know I
don't know I don't really I don't think
about
that I want to have an impact I want to
I want to solve the world's biggest
problem which is untapped human
potential but how do I remembered I
don't know I'm not super worried about
it next Sam yeah could you tell me
something I was setting up a business in
Asia it's not I mean it's not all that
different there's some legal differences
there's some technical differences but
it doesn't make a difference really the
big difference for anybody it's just the
mindset it's just deciding it's just
deciding you know I've spoken in Asia to
Asian entrepreneurs and sometimes
there's more regulations and ten times
it might be a little more difficult to
get going and sometimes you know access
to capital might be a little bit
different but they're all minor
roadblocks like you're gonna have so
many roadblocks in getting your business
off the ground that whatever is
country-specific is super minor and so
if I were you I would not I wouldn't
even ask this question I wouldn't even
think that because you're an Asian
entrepreneur that is any different if I
were you I'd be looking at whoever you
look up to whatever they're Asian or not
and try to study from those success
because almost always is the same thing
and so don't feel like you're limited
and don't feel like you're different if
you take an Asian entrepreneur and stick
them in North America and you take like
the best Asian entrepreneurs stick them
in in the United States they will crush
it and same thing the other way you take
a great American entrepreneur put them
in Asia they're gonna crush it too you
take away all the money from everybody
who has money put them on a new planet
give all the money and make it equal the
people who have all the money here will
have all the money there too it'll just
redistribute back to them so it's not
about where you're from it's about your
mindset
it's not about where you're born it's
about how you act and so I would get it
out of my head that I only want to model
Asian entrepreneurs that the advice is
any different what do we got Sammy
thanks a lot happy to help send me what
do we got what do we got where do I give
you some questions
shady what the heck is that crazy
message okay shady shady if I can catch
you in time shady you're good and you're
going timeout Shh
give me some good stuff here stop
wasting our time a deal
how are you so proactive unlike most
others I think everybody has been
proactive I think everybody can be
proactive I think you just have to have
goals that inspire you I've had lots of
times in my life where I was not
motivated and not happy and and down on
my life on my business from what I was
trying to accomplish and it's a funny
thing when you are on a powerful mission
when you wake up when you are excited
but the work that you're gonna do today
you have energy when I was waking up to
stuff that I hated every day it's really
hard to get out of bed every day and
just want to go do something that you
hate it's really hard and I think most
people are in that situation most people
are gonna they have goals that don't
serve them they have goals that they
don't believe in they're doing work that
they're not a fan of on a regular basis
and so that makes it that makes it all
the more challenging
Christopher welcome thank you for
subscribing and so if I were you I would
start to adjust one so that I have goals
that are motivating for me that inspire
me that I'm on I feel like the work that
I'm doing could potentially matter that
I'm working toward something and then to
creating that designed environment and
habits that support you you know if you
guys are following me on Instagram or
Twitter or snapchat you'll notice that I
start my day the same way you know I
wake up I go to the bathroom I get up 10
minutes before sunrise and I read a page
from my new book coming that December 6
I read a page in that book and get to
great ideas from genius entrepreneurs
and right away it starts to shape me
right I'm waking up I'm in a fog I'm
tired
and then I read to great ideas from
Steve Jobs and I realized you know these
people in this book are thinking big or
tackling their goals or trying to do
something special and it just shifts my
perspective it makes me want to go off
and do something big myself and then so
I read one page it said big glass of
water drink right grab a glass of water
so you're dehydrated in the morning and
then I write down my goals let me show
you here if you haven't followed me on
Instagram there you go that those are my
goals Thursday goals do the best
interviews I've ever done so I'm doing
to interviews I have this hanging out
then I got a bunch of any of you guys
afterwards to pack for Montreal
my wife Nina got a new job and so we're
celebrating by going to Montreal for the
weekend so I got a pack we leave today
and solve the world's biggest problem
and so that's what I do every day I wake
up before sunrise I read a page in the
book I drink a glass of water and I
think about write down the three big
goals that I have for the day and then I
watch the Sun Rise and then I get to
work and I think having that consistent
routine that you do every morning helps
set you up because you've had moments
where you were on fire and energetic and
full of passion and ready to go and
tackle the world and it's just not
consistent so if you can reverse
engineer that to figure out what is it
that got you so motivated and excited
was it reading a book was it watching
the video was it having a conversation
what was it that got you so pumped up
and then designed for that in your
routine so you start your day with that
every day if you did that every day for
the next year you'll be your life will
dramatically change you'll be more
positive you'll be up more optimistic
you'll be way more productive you'll be
attracting people who you know are
interested in your mission you'll just
be you'll be a different person if you
wake up thinking bold things and taking
action every day your life will
dramatically change in a year but it
doesn't just it doesn't just come at
least for me doesn't just come I don't
just wake up and and there's the fire
and the energy I'm tired I went to bed
past two o'clock last night I woke up at
seven with the Sun and I'm tired
I was tired this morning but the routine
sets me up and so that routine works for
me you know reading the book may not
work for you a glass of water may not
work for you although it's probably part
of your you know structure as a human
that it probably will writing down goals
may not work for you but whatever does
work for you find it and then make that
a daily habit what else we got Antoine
Evan enjoy your weekend in Montreal
Congrats Nina thank you for the love
I'll let her know or she'll watch his
back I don't think Nina's ever been to
Montreal part of the fun of being with
Nina is getting to take her new places
and exploring so we're taking my son
Hayden we're
my dog Teemo I'm taking my wife Nina and
we're gonna have a fun I guess three and
a half day trip so I'm excited next
questions what we got
barri Evan I have what I think is a
great website for great products
the issue is we get 30 to 40 quality
quality visitors a day but no one buys
what could be wrong here so first of all
30 to 40 visitors a day is not a lot so
you want to be thinking how can I scale
that up through your traffic through
paid advertising like if you have a
funnel that works if you know that for
every thousand people who visit your
website you're gonna convert well then
you can scale that up and do paid
advertising against it the fastest way
to be able to scale quickly like that is
through advertising but you have to have
a model that works you have to know that
for every dollar you spend you're making
five dollars back or at least two
dollars back you have two challenges one
you're not getting enough traffic 30 to
40 visitors a day is not enough you
could have three sales on one day and
think like you know your conversion
rates are over the moon but the numbers
are so small that nothing that you're
doing is significant from a statistical
perspective right so if you make a
headline change you don't really have
the data to know if that headline change
made a difference or not so one you need
to have more traffic coming to that site
to really see and then to you can
certain measure in conversions so I want
to see you getting a thousand visitors a
day how do you start getting that 500
visitors a day like how do you how do
you start 10 20 times in the traffic to
that website so that you start having
meaningful data as an example you know
you guys are friends on my youtube
channel you're obviously watching here
one of the things that I'm always doing
is split testing so I'm testing new
templates for the top ten you know we
switched it from the the white side to
the black side with the coming up video
and now we have a new test coming out so
as of today or maybe tomorrow you'll see
a new new template coming out I'm always
split testing in what I do is we have as
an example we take assignments INEC top
ten was a success is one of our more
popular ones and we'll run three
different versions of them I'll upload
them as unlisted videos and then I'll
run ad campaigns that
and saw three of them and I see which
one performs the best I love your
quality - feedback - see I like the
sidebar I don't like the sidebar but
it's often the people who leave the
feedback are in them they're in the
minority the vocal minority and so I
want data to show me that hey this
template is working and it's not and so
we'll get 10,000 20,000 30,000 views on
each variation of the video and then
test how long do people stick how long
was the watch time on that video and
then we can make a measurement to say
hey this template works this template
doesn't and so that's what you need for
your website you got to drive more
traffic to the site whether it's organic
or through paid so that you can start
actually testing your assumptions
testing your products testing your
call-to-action
testing your headlines testing your
pricing testing your bonus offers so
that you can really run a data-driven
business that can get some meaningful
results so you have a you have an inflow
problem and you have a conversion
problem you solve both of those you got
an awesome business next web blogger
I don't enjoy my current job as a
software engineer it's going too fast I
have a dream to work for myself and then
it's gone you guys are typing too fast
okay what was it I don't enjoy my okay
you know I think I can scroll up I think
I can scroll up yeah I can scroll up
where was that I don't like my current
job as a software engineer for the
government I have a dream Euler for
myself I want to cook I want to start my
startup I couldn't start please suggest
how I should go okay so first off I'm
not a big I'm not a scroll back down
here for you guys you can keep typing in
your chat I'm not a big fan of quitting
your job and going on and in your
business before you have something there
before you have something that's kind of
established I'm a big believer in
starting your business on the side
making enough money to support yourself
pay your bills just just pay your bills
pay your short-term bills pay your
internet bills you know pay your food
bills pay your housing bills you're not
living a life of luxury but to the point
where you can quit your job and you can
survive and then he can spend way more
time on your business and help it grow
if you have a job the reason to have a
job is one to pay the bills but - or
probably more importantly is to learn so
whatever your startup is I would be
trying to go work for a company where
you're gonna learn the skills that will
help you
see they're so you know are you learning
the technical skills that you need are
you learning entrepreneurial skills that
you need if you're there and you hate
your job and you're learning nothing
you're building zero contacts then quit
that job but instead of going to start
your business full-time because that's
scary and you might run out of cash in
two months I have to go get another job
anyway
go find the company who's doing exactly
what you want to do where you can learn
from the founder we can get closer you
can understand how the interstate works
where you can make contacts where you
can start to build your business on the
side and then again when your business
is making enough money that you're
supporting yourself paying your basics
then you can quit your job and go
full-time the challenging part is you
just have to make sure that you're
spending time every day on your business
between you know life family jobs other
commitments it's often our business our
side hustle our up side project that we
want to turn into something big that
gets sacrificed you come home and you're
tired and you're frustrated with your
boss so you had a bad day you don't want
to work on your company you need to work
on your company you know because
otherwise that dream just stays a dream
it never turns into anything you have to
actually get to work and so 30 to 60
minutes every single day no matter what
no matter what's happening in your life
every day 30 to 60 minutes on your
business and if you do that enough keep
the momentum going and some days you
work we longer but at least 30 to 60
every day you start building momentum
for your company
so one you know get a job where you
going to learn to start your business
part-time on the side and spend 36
minutes every day and then three once
you start making enough money to support
yourself then you quit your job and go
all-in that's my advice
next Monica Evan question what is your
opinion on being positive versus being
realistic thank you I think you need a
healthy dose of both if that makes sense
being positive versus being realistic
you know I think I think I don't I don't
know seriously those opposites you know
I think you know I want to I want to
have a big impact on the world you know
I want to solve the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential I'm
confident I can make a big dent in that
even though it's as big scary imposter
but goal but I also know it's an
impossible goal right it's impossible
it's never gonna happen you know there's
always more potential always no matter
what you do there's always more
potential so I'm reaching for the
impossible goal I'm trying to do what
what Buddha said of wake up every
morning and try to empty the ocean with
a with a spoon with a ladle right and
it's this impossible thing you'll never
empty the ocean with a spoon but you
just wake up every day and you keep
going at it and so I think the most
important thing is that you just don't
get paralyzed by it that you don't just
see positive and optimism as just crazy
dreaming and and you risk everything and
go all in on some strategy that then
blows up in your face and at the same
time I don't see is just making a
realistic plan and just doing the safe
thing and getting the job and not
creating anything new as being really a
viable option for people you know if all
you're doing is being realistic then
you're not living to your potential
understanding that the world that is
around you was created by people who had
a dream and they made something happen
like part of this part of what
entrepreneurs and artists what we do is
we create something that has never been
created before
right now we're creating together
something that has never been created
before the technology has been used
before but what's happening right now
has never been created before you know
the music that you're gonna put out or
that video you're gonna put out or
whatever that thing is that you're gonna
put out has never been done before and
so it's unrealistic to think that you
can do it right it's unrealistic to
think that you can colonize Mars like
Elon must wants to do it's unrealistic
cuz it hasn't been done before right
it's not practical because it's never
been done before but if you just always
live in the world of practicality and
what's been done then I think that's
extremely limiting I think you need to
have both I think you make the big
decisions in your life with your heart
and that might be the the optimistic
side right like here's what I'm
passionate about here's the thing I want
to create here's my mission here's my
vision here's the here's what I make so
excited to get up and do
you know I want to help you guys I want
to help entrepreneurs I wake up and you
know I go through my routine and like I
can't wait I'm telling my wife Nina over
breakfast like I get to do my live chat
today somebody invited me to go to their
office is like no I can't come I'm gonna
be late I gotta go to my live chat I
want to hang out with these guys and so
like doing work that you love even
though it doesn't make sense that starts
with your heart and it happens over and
over and over again you know people
covered in the book that's coming out
December 6 almost all of them like they
did they took a rest that didn't make
practical sense and it paid off because
you make the big decisions in life with
your heart the small ones in life the
small decisions I make with your head
the small decisions are now how to
actually take action on it that's where
you can start getting pragmatic and
realistic and thinking about what makes
sense so as an example you know I want
to have a big impact to help
entrepreneurs great
I want to make youtube videos I love
videos that's that's more pragmatic
right it's more realistic what do I
that's thinking right what do i what how
do my skills line up with with what I
can do to have that impact you know I
like making videos I like doing
spontaneous stuff I like helping people
with this kind of format instead of just
typing email responses to people and
then you can get even more niche and
micro with okay if I'm making YouTube
videos then what do I title the video
and what tags do I use and how do I make
my thumbnail more appealing and how do I
use playlists all of those things are
are head strategies right the head helps
you figure out the how but the why is
the most important thing if you lead
with the head you're just living in a
world that already exists if you leave
with the heart you're off creating a new
world that only you can create and
that's where all the great leaders are
great artists great entrepreneurs this
way they live and that's where I want
you to live so big decisions with the
heart small ones with the head you need
both alright that was a good that was a
good mini rant Kirk can you give tips on
upcoming musicians when it comes to
YouTube and in general please Kirk I
love this question if I was a musician
what I would be doing is what I'm doing
right now with my youtube channel daily
content
I would start by figuring out what your
style is right you know if you're rock
if you're RMB if you're a rapper if
you're some kind of mix of this new
hybrid form of musician that you want to
create you know I would I would start
with that and then I'd be looking at how
can I make daily content to start
building my fan base and I would start
with cover songs I think too many people
are attached to their own music it's
great to have your own music but you
have such an easy option to start in to
start infiltrating your style like you
may be able to take a Justin Bieber song
that's popular and turn it into
something like maybe you hate Bieber but
you can turn that into something really
special through your style right and
that starts bringing in the people to
get to know you like you trust you want
to hear more of your stuff and I get
that making original music will take
more time and it depends on how creative
and how you know quickly you can riff
and get those things going but I would I
would be doing like 80% cover songs 20%
original music and I'd be doing daily
content the musicians who do that
they're gonna dominate they're gonna be
the next the next five years the
musicians who are doing daily content
one they get better if you're making a
song a day you're gonna get better
you just will you'll get better you know
I've gotten better as a speaker I've
gotten more comfortable in front of the
camera because I've done five
thousand-plus videos go back to my
channel look at look at my first videos
look at how awkward I was how nervous I
was the points were still good the
content was still good but the delivery
just sucked because I was nervous and I
was I was not confident I've never done
this kind of stuff before and so the
more you practice you know the Beatles
example the 10,000 hours example you
know the more you practice the better
you're gonna get so if you're making
daily songs daily content you're just
gonna get better and you're gonna start
building audience you're gonna start
building traction I've made a series on
my channel that's ending now because I
hit a million subscribers soon but it's
it's how I got two million subscribers
and one of the things that just really
helped my channel explode was going to
daily content and I compare myself to
other channels and other people who I
felt were better speakers and me
and look at guys like Eric Thomas if you
guys know Eric thomas ET hip-hop
preacher dude is is amazing you know
he's the Les Brown of our generation and
this he's just an awesome speaker in my
channel past his why it's not because
I'm super talented Varma genius I'm just
putting out way more content than he is
right I'm doing three videos a day and
he's doing one a week a couple week I
haven't checked recently right now with
YouTube's algorithm that's what they
want to see and so I think as a musician
your talent is you and if you can put
out daily content eighty percent cover
songs twenty percent your own original
stuff or even you know ninety ten or who
takes to you like you can only do one
original a month great you know one
original month and twenty nine days of
covers and it doesn't have to be crazy
highly edited it doesn't have to be full
production music videos get your phone I
where's my phone I recorded a video
today that's coming out tomorrow talking
about my book launch and my million
subscriber livestream like I need guys
guys I need strata using the advice what
should I do for my million I'm gonna hit
a million subscribers on Monday or
Tuesday and I don't know what I'm gonna
do yet with it I want it to be special
and fun and have giveaways and I don't
have a plan yet so I made a quick video
asking asking for your feedback and I
just got on my phone that's it and I
recorded there's a couple minutes long
and I'm uploading it and you know we're
gonna see what you guys have to say and
my channel has a million subscribers and
I'm still making videos from my phone
this one is coming from a webcam I'm
last human to you from a webcam right
like don't get stuck on the gear doesn't
have to be perfect your art is your song
your art is your creativity it's not you
know if you were an editor that'd be a
different story right if you were gonna
get hired for your editing skills then
I'm looking at your editing I'm looking
at your video production but your
musician just set up a camera and start
doing covers and start expressing your
style and getting used to your voice I
want to see it I'm so pumped to see
whoever does it because
it's simple advice but it's hard to do
and if you can actually just put in the
work and get it done the artists that do
that are gonna explode over the next
five years what else kept day Jeff day
hope I pronounced that okay any tips for
reducing self-doubt
thank you sir keep up the great work so
you know self-doubt is normal you know
even I I face it even though my one word
is believed right and I'm preaching that
I think what happens is as you take on
bigger projects your your circle of
confidence increases right so at the
beginning I was doing really small
projects and anything else I was a
little scary now I can do bigger and
bigger projects but if you wanted me to
go speak at a you know hundred thousand
person stadium dad I'm gonna have some
self dad that's gonna be a little bit
scary right and so a couple of things
that helped me in that the biggest thing
that's helped me the biggest thing
honestly the biggest thing has helped me
is just changing my environment to be
around big thinking confident people and
that hasn't been through people in my
network cuz I don't really know a lot of
big thinking competent confident people
my friends are awesome but they're not
doing things that I look I'd say wow I
can't believe look at look at what she's
doing I want to copy that
and so I get it from my channel I get it
from the videos like I make new videos
for you guys but first and foremost if
for me I'm selfish there for me and the
book like I read the book every morning
one page because it sets my mindset and
the story that I tell around that is I
used to be afraid to go and talk to a
single entrepreneur I remember that I
had this moment and I was I had a
meeting booked with entrepreneur
start-up entrepreneur this woman who
wanted to start a coffee shop or
something just brand new startup
entrepreneur and I had already done
speeches and I'd already learned a lot
of you know one-on-ones and lots of
emails I was really making youtube
videos you know I was secretly hoping
that she would cancel the meeting on me
I was secretly hoping that she would
email me and say having having a heaven
hey Evan
I'm sick you know or I'm stuck I can't
make it but bah-bah-bah I would always
kind of seek really hope people would
cancel
on me because really at the end of the
day I was just scared that I wasn't
gonna be able to bring them value I was
just worried that I would waste their
time and and I wouldn't be able to bring
them any value in that meeting and I
also knew that this was also what I
loved
like I loved helping you guys I love
meeting people one-on-one I loved
speaking at events it's such a thrill in
such a high and the ending is so amazing
and the feedback afterwards it's why I
do what I do and yet it's also my
biggest fear and so I remember that
morning this is the one to hit me the
hardest I'm ten minutes away from
meeting her I'm checking my email hoping
that she cancels on me and she didn't
cancel so I got to show up right so I go
I show up we meet at a coffee shop local
Starbucks and it was an awesome meeting
just awesome you know such a wonderful
woman
I had a great conversation I really
helped her I really you know helped her
believe in herself gave her some great
ideas so she can go execute for her
business and then I remember after we
met I went back to my car and I'm
sitting in the car it's like I feel so
great and I can't believe that I wanted
her to cancel the meeting like what
would happen if she canceled I would not
be having this amazing joy right now and
I just decided you know what modeling
success had really worked for me in the
past looking at Bill Gates saved my
first business and it was what my
channel was all about I needed to do it
more often because what what happened
was I would have a problem how do I sell
more software great look at Bill Gates
get inspired go out and apply it see a
spike and then come back to normal and I
said if I need if I want to make this a
consistent thing if I want to change my
belief structure if I want to stop being
so nervous and so afraid and filled with
self-doubt that I need to change who I'm
hanging out with on a permanent basis
and that's when I started really going
deep on daily daily following successful
entrepreneurs daily following people
with visionary game-changing ideas and
it
started happening slowly by slowly I
didn't even notice a change until a year
or two later I was driving with my dad
to go get a new car for him and I had
just signed a deal with Stephen Kelly
who's the CEO of sage and sage is a
multi-billion dollar company has you
know thirteen thousand employees and
we're doing a Q&A session together and
he's answering questions and I'm
answering questions and my dad asked
well how do you get the how do you get
the courage to see yourself as being
equal to Stephen Kelly and he wasn't
asking in a way that puts me down
he was asking like how'd it like that's
awesome how do you how do you see
yourself because he he's a super humble
guy and I just I didn't even think about
it because the people that I hang out
with on a daily basis are these guys a
Steve Jobs it's Oprah Winfrey it's the
people in my book you're like I'm around
those people daily even if I've never
met them you know I'm consuming their
content through videos and reading books
and because I do it daily slowly by
slowly I start to shift
I start to change I start to think
bigger I start to believe in myself more
I start to have bolder ideas and a
bolder vision and getting to the point
where getting on a call with a CEO of a
huge company wasn't a massively
nerve-wracking thing here's a guy who
has a multi-billion dollar company
13,000 employees and I'm not afraid
getting on that call but you know year
or two before I was afraid to go meet a
brand new startup entrepreneur at a
coffee shop who I knew I could help
write like how does that shift happen
it's that daily consistent habit and I
didn't even realize it until that
conversation with my father of how far
I've grown and again I'm not a genius
and not anything special I was just the
same you know shyness person who wanted
to be loved and felt worthy and changing
that one thing in my environment really
made a difference it's why I decided
with writing this book
I held off and writing the book for a
long time I didn't think like why write
the book I don't want people just
blasting through the book you know it's
- you're not gonna get enough from it
it's not gonna really make an impact in
terms of you actually taking action in
your business the shift the reason why I
started this book the top ten roses
success was what if you just read one
page a day like the difference is not
just getting the ideas once it's getting
the consistency it's being around these
people every day and so I tested it
myself on each page there's two rules
from one legendary person like Steve
Jobs is our first entrepreneur you open
it up one page is two rules from him he
said it's two of the best things Eve job
has ever said in his life just read that
one page absorb it think about how to
apply it to your life in your business
and then the next day go read and the
next page instead of blasting through
like fifty rules and they're not doing
anything with it read one page and if
you do that every day it's crazy how
much you start to change and start to
believe in yourself more and start to go
after bigger bolder badder things and
you may not see the difference overnight
you may not see the difference day to
day but you'll have those moments like
it like I did with my dad and talking
about the CEO or you'll see friends we
haven't seen in in a month or two it'll
be like your your chain like what
happened your your your totally
different you're way more confident way
more optimistic and way more
hard-working what happened and you may
not see those daily changes but the
people around you especially when they
haven't seen you for a while will and so
changing that habit I think if you want
to be more confident you don't just read
ten ways to be more confident not just a
practical how to's it's being around
confident people it rubs off on you so
many huge difference in my life and
hopefully makes a difference in yours
too all right what do we got more
questions how we doing on time
well we ready at the half an hour mark
I'm talking a lot hopefully you guys are
liking these stories what do we got Rita
Kaiser Evan I'm 17 years old I am 17
years old the girl that I love in my
class
as well as her boyfriend but she doesn't
love me they always kiss in class and I
lived this fact helped me overcome this
it's a relationship advice now ah I
don't know what you want to overcome if
you want to forget about it you want to
move on you want to win her over
having clarity will help you lit just
like in the business having clarity for
what you want helps make an impact in
terms of in terms of like getting the
wand in terms of whether it's
relationship or business like I really
want to work with one client I really
want to get that client you need to
really make sure that you're you're
you're chasing that for the right
reasons right like you're so in love
with this person what do you really even
know them you badly want to work with
that celebrity but why like do you
really even know them like there's so
many people who might be better fits for
you but you get infatuated with one
customer or one person like this has to
be the one now I love Nina right I know
her we've been married for a number of
years right it's a it's totally
different than just a passion or the
lust that you have the beginning like
it's a deep love if you're on that level
that's something else but if it's just
an infatuation you know understand where
it's coming from you don't even know
this person
there was a great line I think was from
a movie where the Yankees lost you know
they lost some big game they lost the
World Series or something and the boy
who was a fan of the Yankees was crying
and then the father of the uncle the
older brother whoever it was said why
are you why are you crying over you know
Mickey Mantle losing or Joe DiMaggio
losing like why you because why you so
invested why are you crying so much
Mickey Mantle isn't crying about you
Mickey Mantle doesn't even know who you
are I found that really interesting why
do you care so much
I built this girl why do you care so
much about getting that client I know
the reason is actually based in anything
that's going to serve you in the long
term and so
I appreciate the question haven't had to
answer that one for a while Joanne Cruz
hello you've been featuring a lot of
successful entrepreneurs on your videos
if you will be given a chance to meet
one of them in person who will it be
what will he or she advise you um that's
an interesting question I'm a weird bird
and that I have very little interest in
meeting almost anybody mostly cuz I
don't know what I would ask them you
know my favorite entrepreneur all-time
was AP Giannini he's back there
I love consuming his content there's not
a lot of it so it's difficult I love
Howard Schultz behind me I love Steve
Jobs I got Kanye in the corner back
there you can't see him I don't know
what I would ask them you put me in a
room with Howard Schultz I don't I don't
have a question for him you know that I
think that's my biggest challenges I
don't know what I would want to ask them
where I can get some value from I've
learned a lot from him I've learned a
lot from Steve Jobs and Tony Robbins and
Oprah Winfrey but you put me in a room
with them like okay I I have no interest
in meeting them not I'd have like an ego
or anything not that I'm better than
them or I would you know snub them I'd
be happy to mean I just have no interest
because I don't know what I would want
to be able to ask them if I had to pick
two people one I would say AP Giannini
who's my favorite entrepreneur all-time
who's passed on mostly because it's not
there's not a lot of content on him
there's no interviews there's no video
and I I would love to be able to have
content people don't know his story
people who are at his company now you
know even in the PR department like I've
never heard of him like this is your
founder you know and so I would love to
be able to tell the story and recognize
what a great entrepreneur he was that
and if it wasn't him somebody living it
be a toss-up between Howard Schultz and
Kanye West Howard I just I just love a
lot of what he stands for Kanye would be
more because I feel like a lot of the
interviews that he's done haven't
haven't gone down the right path it's
always focusing on the negative stuff
and the tabloids and the controversies
and that's definitely part of what he's
all about
there's also a lot of a lot of genius in
him and you know the sky is one more
Grammy Awards and anybody at his age
ever any transition from beads to making
music to being an entrepreneur and
having a clothing line and shoes and all
that stuff and so there's a lot that you
could learn from him when I don't feel
like his story's been told well and so I
would want to ask questions to help tell
that but it's not for me you know it's
interesting that none of those things
are for me it's it's I would like to
help spread their message more I would
like Kanye story to come out more I
would like AP Giannini story to come out
more I would like Howard Schultz's story
to come out more and I just get
frustrated with the content that's out
there and people asking questions that
I'm not interested in but I've heard
from that yeah I don't know I don't have
anybody
it's just it's I could be doing a lot
more interviews on this channel I don't
reach out to anybody the ones that I do
they're incoming we did TD jakes he's
promoting his book we did Ryan holiday
last week he's got a new book that's
coming out or that just came out
we got Lewis house coming up soon Tony
Robbins people want to do something
people reach out to me wanted to get
some exposure and attention and it's
fine like we can have a great discussion
but I don't really have any interest
there's nothing I would ask I think
that's the biggest thing thank you for
the question I know I'm a weird one in
that in that respect next add maria evan
daily documentation example vlog live
versus daily creating original depends
what you're good at that's what you can
do you can make a vlog every day it can
be super boring so that's not really
gonna help you that much unless you
really want to get better at it and then
you just expect to suck at the beginning
and you get better and better and better
as you go daily creating if you're
creating original content that's great
if you're great at that it's it's not
only those two buckets you could do
daily interviewing you know what is that
is that vlogging no is that creating no
your you have a co-host writer you have
someone who you regularly doing an
interview with and a show with or you
have somebody who you bring on you have
special guests like I just talked about
Ryan holiday Tony Robbins or whoever in
your industry that you're curious
interested by
there's no one right answer I think
doing something daily though the daily
practice one just to practice to get
better we talked about this before with
the musician the quantity leads to the
quality the more you do it the better
you'll get you want to be world-class as
something you're not just gonna wake up
and be world-class at it you got to
you've got to practice you got to put in
the work you got to hustle so doing a
daily will help you get the skills to be
great and then to just in the the
economy that we're in right now that's
that's the game if you can go daily if
you can you know you'll win on YouTube
you'll you'll beat people who are better
than you because you're going Delian
they're not because you understand how
the market works right now and they
don't so it's a it's a chance it's a
window before the big companies get in
and start doing these kinds of things
like I shouldn't exist my channel
shouldn't exist like CNN should have
already done what I'm doing all these
big networks should have already done
what I'm doing I've had channel with a
million subscribers that shouldn't have
happened it's it's only happened because
CNN and Fox and ABC and all these
companies they close their eyes they
have better talent they have better
production they have more money more
resources more experience than I do and
I was I'm able to crush most of their
shows like how many of their shows have
a million followers just because I'm
doing what the market is interested in
and they're slow and so you can you
still have time to take advantage of
that
so whatever helps you get out daily now
I think it's really really important one
is not better than the other you could
look at key scene I stats vlog or any of
the guys who are logging and that's how
they would they go all in you know I
don't vlog I do a little bit but it's
like my vlogs are the worst part of my
channel you know my vlogs have the
lowest views of any videos I make on my
channel and that's fine I do it for fun
and do it for the connection to you guys
I'm gonna go to Montreal this weekend
and I'll probably vlog chunks of that
we'll see so the answer is you got to do
you just make sure that you're doing
something daily
next dr. cook Evan how much do you work
per week on this channel I don't know
man
it's the wrong question like when you
love what you do you put in the work you
know I work I have typical workdays I
guess working hours but I'm always
thinking about my channel I'm always
thinking about you guys I'm always
taking in my business and what's next
and my vision and my goals and my dreams
and what I want to accomplish I think as
soon as you see it as I'm gonna only do
you know my work is is 40 hours a week
and you're on the clock like if you're
watching the clock you're in the wrong
business you know like I said before you
want to be working at least 30 to 60
minutes a day on your company but if
you're like okay oh my 30 minutes is up
whoo you're in the wrong thing you got
to have work 4:30 my god I can't wait I
can't believe I have to stop like I want
to keep going and I think you'll find
that with most people who are successful
whatever they do musicians athletes
anybody you wanna be able to get lost in
your work and as soon as you're counting
the hours you lose so I don't know I
don't think I I just disagree with the
question but thank you for asking I got
to clarify next Skies owed how to cope
with depression when you're young and no
one even close ones show support you
know that's a rough one I haven't I
haven't been through you know I wouldn't
call anything like clinical depression I
think my business suffering at the
beginning and me wanted to quit was the
hardest moment in my life but I haven't
gone through what I think most people
consider depression so you take it with
a grain of salt I think I think the
people around you in the environment is
really important but I don't think you
can just blame it on having copy people
around you I think you need to you make
your own circumstances so first step is
the people who aren't supporting you the
people who you know they either do
they're just not supporting you or worse
or hating on you they're saying you suck
you'll never be anything you're you know
they're the little man of the people who
just beat you down right eliminating
those people from your life or at least
limiting exposure to them
we're gonna have 100% of the people in
your life are either non-supportive or
the little man that's a rough way to
live that's a crappy existence and so
limiting exposure or cutting them out I
say that because like maybe it's your
mom and maybe you don't want to cut your
mom out of your life and some people do
some people do is like mom you don't
support me you know you're my biggest
hater that's it until you can support me
I'm out some people can make that that
leap and it's the best thing for them
others you know you you still want your
mom in your life but just limiting the
exposure and also limiting what you talk
about you know if any time you bring up
your aspirations your your career goals
or your dreams you just get pounded on
you just make it real not to talk about
that stuff and you talk about family
stuff and you talk about fun stuff that
you're working on you talk about your
relationship or you talk about other
things that you know aren't going to be
hot hot button topics that lead to more
depression for you so eliminate them or
limit your exposure and now you have
this gap now you have this extra time
right you're not spending time with
these people because you've cut them out
or you've limited exposure so how do you
feel the void and my solution has been
through aspirational mentors you know I
learn a lot by watching and so I like
videos you know I've talked before but
how the videos kind of shaped my
perspective and gave me more confidence
and more self belief if you didn't catch
it and so you can go back and watch the
replay and so it could be definitely
people like face to face if you're that
kind of person you need to have people
around you then look for events that are
happening look for meetups look for
groups look for you know conferences
that you can go to look for any
activities that are happening in your
ear that you can meet up with people who
might be like-minded around a certain
topic you can join things like this you
know I love believe nation you guys are
what I think is the most supportive
amazing community and you were on the
planet you know we have some haters like
everybody does but if you come on and
share your idea and you're looking for
people just to support you I think it's
a great place to do it I've seen so many
comments in the videos where somebody
says their idea and then somebody else
replies and says that go forward or
here's some suggestions it's usually a
very uplifting positive community I
haven't seen you know all the comments
coming through because I'm talking but
in general it's super positive and
uplifting which is great and so like
hanging out here or in other online
communities right like just don't a lot
of times you just see the limitations of
what's put in front of you and you just
accept that as your life and that's a
really small way of thinking you know I
don't have friends that push me to want
to do more but I'm not gonna accept that
as a limitation I'm gonna go out and
find a different path and for me it was
by reading biographies reading other
books watching videos and surrounding
myself with those people even though
I've never met them
you know my favorite entrepreneur is a
dead man I'm never gonna meet him but
I've learned a lot from him and I still
can learn more from him and so
illuminating and reduced in exposure to
those negative people and then replacing
them with uplifting people whether
that's face to face whether that's
online people that you connect with or
whether that's aspirational people that
you look up to and surround yourself
with I think it starts to turn the time
to make a difference for you I really do
and and the consistency like once a week
isn't enough every day if it's if it's
such an ingrained thing for you if it's
so deep within you that you should
really struggle with it then it has to
be every day it's got to be a daily
thing if you fall off once it's okay but
like you want to get in shape you got to
eat well every day you can have the
occasional chocolate bar but you got to
eat well every day you know so if you
really want to fix that it'd be looking
at changing it and being consistent
every day thank you all the guys
subscribing I love that Gary welcome
aboard
what else we have rs please advise
first-time entrepreneur I'm finding it
hard to find a co-founder who has the
same wavelength will this to turn me
from getting seed funding so there's a
lot of lot of stuff there first off you
know your co-founder if you're going to
bring on a partner you want to make sure
that you're on the same wavelength you
want to make sure you share similar
values you know whether use the one word
exercise you can't see the book here or
something else
I think people too often jump into
business partnerships based off of skill
sets and not off of values so I'm a
great salesman and you're great
programmer so let's partner up and have
business together just because it looks
good on paper doesn't mean it's gonna
work out now you're gonna spend as much
time with this person as you will with
your husband or wife and so you want to
make sure that you know that somebody
that you fit the same values from in
terms of seed funding first off I don't
know how much time I even spend trying
to get seed funding because you spend so
much time churning trying to get through
investors that you're not just spending
time on your business where you want to
be out working on your business and the
more momentum that you have the easier
it is to get funding so I'd be trying to
find a ways to get started get some
trash and get some get some money coming
in doesn't have to be massively
profitable but just showing that you can
make some money already separates you
from 99% of everybody else going out and
pitching investors so you send a much
better chance to get investment you
spend less time going after investors
and you lose a lot less of the company
because you're a less risky investment
at the moment to most companies that
succeed they're not going venture
capital they're not going and getting
seed funding right they just go on they
start any creating the bootstrap it up
and so I would really advise you to go
off and do that if you are hell-bent on
getting a seed funding does a partner
help you it can it just depends on what
the skill sets that you need what are
you trying to build and can you do it
yourself you know if I'm trying to build
a YouTube channel what are the skill
sets that I need you know do I need to
have an on-air personality yeah is that
me am I good enough great I can do that
do we need to have a great editor sure
can I hire that or does that need to be
a co-founder right if you're a technical
company though as an example and you are
not the technical person you need to
have somebody technical in your business
show me a technology company that
doesn't have some technology expertise
as a co-founder right so those things
could potentially hurt you
but again one you know make sure people
you bring it on board especially early
you share similar values with two I
wouldn't even honestly worry about seed
funding go out and start hustling and
bringing some customers
and then look at expansion funding and
then just do the skills analysis what
you need to be able to continue to scale
this business up next Jorge how to
promote your ebook if you're not popular
in social media yet so I'm gonna give
you two strategies for that Jorge and
having gone through one book launch and
now December 6 next book coming out I'm
super excited for it the short term play
for you is to find people who have a
similar audience and they can resonate
with your book and the message in it and
so what I'll be doing is try to find
influencers people who have an audience
who can help get your message out there
and you target them with a tailored
message so as an example if you were
just to write to me and say hey I have a
new book Evan can check it out I'm
probably gonna ignore it because I don't
know who you are and it's great now that
you asked me this question maybe I
recognize you a little bit more but
there's other people who are part of
believe nation my cz know they're in a
chat you see that little blue wrench
that's Z know if Xena wrote an e-book
and he reached me up and said hey Evan
can you check it out I would because
Xena's contributed a lot to this
community because his in a lot of live
chats because he's added a lot of value
and so that's what I would be doing if I
was trying to reach out to other
influencers I'd be looking at getting
involved in their community as much as
possible engaging as much of their
content as possible responding to the
YouTube videos retweeting their stuff
supporting them before you go ask for
support yourself go support them you
want to be a known quantity you want
them to recognize your name and your
picture when you send them an email or
message is asking for help most people
get this wrong most people just spam
married a whole bunch of messages and
hope they get a reply surprise surprise
they don't it doesn't work because they
spent no time investing in the
relationship so why would that influence
her with a million followers or however
many it is why would they spend time
reading through your proposal when
you've done nothing for them first right
it's like give first give give give and
then you have permission to ask and
hopefully make a connection to I would
start with people who are in your
industry and you
Oh already resonate with the first the
first collaborations I did for YouTube
for me was Derral Eve's and Tim Schmoyer
I think Tim was first and there was
second and if you don't know those guys
they're great guys to follow for how to
build a YouTube channel I learned a lot
from them as I was building up my
channel and I was a fan of their channel
right like I knew them and what they
were interested in because I watched
enough of their videos and I was leaving
comments on their videos and when I sent
them a message say hey how about this
idea
they recognized who I was because I left
so many comments on their videos and so
the people who you're already following
who you already feel a connection with
for whatever reason even if they don't
know you yet those are typically the
best people to reach out to as opposed
to let me make a list of everybody with
a million followers and then I'm gonna
just spam out messages to them right so
that is the short term strategy find
people who already have an audience and
market to them the longer term and what
I feel is actually more effective
strategy just takes more work is to
build your own is to understand what
your one word is what your value system
is what you believe the market you want
to make and start building up your own
audience whether that's a YouTube
channel whether that's Twitter you know
if you like writing so it could be
Twitter it could be long-form Facebook
post it could be medium there's a lot of
platforms if you're targeting a business
audience could be LinkedIn and start
building up your own platform because if
I look at okay I'm gonna launch this
book right December 6 this comes out
most of the sales are gonna make in the
launch and over the next X number of
years will come from my own audience
will come from you guys because there's
value built in because you're fans of my
content because you've watched the
videos because I talk about how I'm
using the book in my daily process cuz
I'm not just trying to sell something to
make money I want to sell it to you so
that you can improve your habits and
improve your business right I'm gonna
sell most of my books through my own
platform even though I have a lot of
friends who have big influence and lots
of channels and great social media reach
as well as traditional media and I'll
hit those guys up and I'm sure I'll be
on their shows and all that stuff and
it'll be lots of fun and I've great
respect and admiration
for them I'm super thankful and grateful
to be on their programs but I'm still
gonna sell the most through my audience
and every day I gain more traction with
my audience every day I gain more power
with my audience I gain more influence
with my audience and it's a long-term
asset right that I'll sell X number of
you know so the example right if I
compare these two books right this is
gonna sell more than this and launch
because my audience has grown right like
I launched that one a year ago and I had
how many subscribers you know I don't
know how many but I'm all bigger now
right we're gaining 1500 subscribers a
day so I'm gonna sell more because my
audience is just bigger and so if you
have zero audience and you're launching
an e-book right now I get that that's a
pain point and you want to you want to
sell your book so use influencers do the
strategies I recommended the long-term
play though is to work on your own
audience and figure out how your a book
like I still talk about your one word
it's not that it's a book that was just
published last year and that's it okay
launch race is done it's over now that
the message is still core to what I
believe in and will always be like in 20
years I'll still be talking about your
one word it's part of an ongoing process
with it whether I'm still doing YouTube
videos or I'm doing VR entrepreneurship
or whatever it is holographic you know
I'd be pretty cool you get to sit in the
hologram with Steve Jobs giving you
wisdom that'd be awesome
we'll see we'll get there but I'll still
be talking about your one word that's
something I believe in to my core I'll
still be talking about Marla success and
so the much more powerful long to
employees you continue to build up your
audience you continue to find ways to
work in the messaging from the book that
you've created because it's a it's not a
sales message I'm not I'm not talking to
you about this book because I want to
sell the book I want you to get better
right like I don't want you guys to have
these problems I want you to be able to
build an amazing business and this is
what I use to help build mine it's the
only strategies that I know so I'm
sharing it out of a sincere hope that
you guys will take it and do something
with it
if you don't get value from the book let
me know like I'll be dead
stated it's a personal fliction so you
know I've recognized how hard it is to
just write a book it's crazy the amount
of work just to write a book and most
people think they're done even harder is
it to promote the book like writing the
book is is ten percent of work 90
percent is then actually going out of
marketing and selling it and making
those connections short-term and
building your own audience long term and
so I would pick the one platform that
you resonate most with again if you like
to write
I'd be looking at more writing kind of
stuff so you can actually have fun
building your audience responding to
people interacting with people and then
continue to build up that influence you
don't have to be everywhere you don't
need to have a YouTube channel
don't worry about it don't focus on
having a YouTube channel if you don't
want to be in front of a camera it's
okay there's lots of ways to build up
different audiences pick the medium that
fits best for you and start building
that up I think an easy strategy for you
especially as getting newsletters one of
the biggest mistakes I made in the in
the first book and grade 2 the second
the first so the first page of this book
do you want free bonuses there's a whole
bunch of free bonuses that I had in this
book that nobody got because a lot of
the sales you know we're made by people
going to Amazon and they went through
just through my newsletter list and I
wanted people's email addresses so I can
send them with all the bonuses and it's
kind of buried in the first bug it's
buried you have to really read through
to find it and I didn't think about it
so the second book I gets right there
upfront so if you collect the email
addresses of the people who are buying
your book then you can send them updates
you can make them part of your community
you can ask them what questions they
need help with and then when you're
ready to launch the second book you have
you know base of people that you can
promote to and expose yourself to as
well woo that's an hour guys it's crazy
how I don't know if it flew bat flew
flew by flew by as quickly as for you as
it did for me but thank you for the love
I really liked this idea of once a week
on Thursday being able to answer
questions with you I'm going to try to
keep it up either
with me solo like this or I have a guest
on I like this new format with the
questions showing up on the screen and
like Pikachu showing up and showing the
new subscribers so I'll continue to play
around and test with that as well thank
you guys so much for all the love I'm
heading to Montreal with Nina and we'll
be thinking about you guys I'll see you
again next week Monday or Tuesday
livestream 1 million subscribers
probably again on Thursday and then the
following Wednesday maybe for the book
launch
we'll see give me your ideas when you
see the video tomorrow think about it
today and when you see the video
tomorrow leave me some great comments in
the video I'm gonna be checking for
Montreal thank you guys to the love have
an amazing Thursday rest of the day I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love guys I'll see you soon